sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Landsleute
Herr März Jahren auf die Rede von Herrn
Bundeskanzler wieder Design entsetzt
weil Teile gefehlt haben was ich in
allen meinen Vorrednern auch in ihrer
Rede eben nicht gehört habe und was mich
entsetzt hat dass sie kaum ein Wort über
das eigene Land verloren haben dass sie
kaum ein Wort über die Sorgen und Nöte
der deutschen Bevölkerung verloren haben
das sagt eigentlich alles aus
bereits die vergangenen
asien-gipfeltreffen haben uns nämlich
auch eines gezeigt die Staaten wollen
sich nicht zwischen zwei
Verhandlungspartnern entscheiden darin
haben sie uns und Europa mittlerweile
einiges voraus sie Wägen die
zusammenarbeiten mich interessengeleitet
ab anstelle sich durch Sanktionen zu
separieren und China meine Damen und
Herren gehört zu Asien geographisch
kulturell und wirtschaftlich Differenzen
gibt es auch dort überall die kann man
jedoch nur gemeinsam beraten ohne die
komplette Öffentlichkeit in die eine
oder die andere Richtung zu
instrumentalisieren so kann jeder sein
Gesicht waren und Missverständnisse
werden so auch vermieden und genau diese
sind in den letzten Monaten schon oft
genug als Konfrontation wahrgenommen
worden und das Werte Kollegen genau das
gilt es auch zu vermeiden wir brauchen
Zusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe niemand
möchte sich zuerst mit ideologischen
Denkansätzen seines Gegenüber
beschäftigen für eine welche Welt ist
der respektvolle Umgang miteinander der
erste Schritt
und gerade
gerade die aktuelle Situation in
Deutschland zeigt dass wir als ein Land
ohne Rohstoffe und mit hoher Inflation
es uns überhaupt nicht erlauben können
ständig wirtschaftliche Sanktionen im
Namen der sogenannten wir haben es ja
heute wieder gehört feministischen
Außenpolitik zu erlassen dieses
Instrument schadet Deutschland ebenso
nachhaltig wie seinen Bürgern und genau
das muss ein Ende haben
und schon längst reden wir nicht mehr
nur über Russland mittels
Berichterstattung zur innenpolitischen
Auseinandersetzungen sendet die
Bundesregierung Signale an unliebsam
gewordene Länder aus wir haben es heute
auch gehört diese sorgen dort zumindest
für Erstaunen bis hin zu Unverständnis
denn über Jahrzehnte und das muss man ja
auch mal sagen hat man vernünftig
kommuniziert diplomatische Standards
gewahrt und wirtschaftlichen Austausch
gepflegt das waren die Leitlinien
deutscher Außenpolitik der letzten
Jahrzehnte aber spätestens seit dieser
Ampel Regierung stehen ideologische
Lehrstunden gegenüber anderen Nationen
und Kulturen mittlerweile auf der
Tagesordnung man unterscheidet nur noch
zwischen gut und schlecht zwischen
Schwarz und Weiß und da frage ich sie
können sie sich meine Damen und Herren
eigentlich noch vorstellen dass diese
Stimmung mittlerweile als feindselig
aufgenommen wird und die Frage sie wem
nutzt das
meinen sie das hilft den Menschen vor
Ort in den Ländern und ja die geführten
Auseinandersetzungen sind in Teilen auch
gewalttätig was wir als Alternative für
Deutschland auch nicht verteidigen ist
man aber ein besserer und
vertrauensvoller Partner wenn man von
außen einen vielleicht gewaltsamen
Regimewechsel aktiv Hawaii führen möchte
natürlich nicht sie stellen sich und
damit Deutschland dauerhaft vollkommen
ins Abseits das trägt weder zufrieden in
der Region oder der Welt bei noch nutzt
ist den deutschen Bürgern mit ihrer
Politik teilen sie die Welt in zwei
Hälften Schotten Deutschland einseitig
ab und treiben so auch die Idee
Industrialisierung weiter voran
sie setzen mittlerweile den längst
eingeschlagenen Kurs der
Merkel-Regierung vor dass der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland schon
seit Jahren immer weniger attraktiv ist
zeigt die steigende Zahl der Firmen die
bereits abgewandert sind oder die es
planen und diese Zahlen die sind
alarmierend und die müssen auch im
Wirtschaftsministerium mittlerweile
angekommen werden sie konnte man in der
FAZ am 30 November diesen Jahres
nachlesen dass bei einer Umfrage des
Statistischen Bundesamtes unter 600
mittelständischen Unternehmen
mittlerweile 20 Prozent bereits konkrete
Pläne haben Deutschland zu verlassen und
das ist nicht der Anfang von 2018 bis
2020 gingen bereits 1,6% der deutschen
Firmen diesen Weg also lange vor den
geeignissen des Jahres
2020 und sehr bedenklich sind zudem die
Geschäftsbereiche die vorrangig
ausgelagert wurden darunter die
Warenproduktion und deren Vertrieb aber
auch die Forschung und Entwicklung also
das letzte Know-how der letzte Rohstoff
Forschung und Entwicklung wandert
mittlerweile
und da verstehen sie da wirklich die
Signale ich weiß es nicht zuerst wurden
Produktionsprozesse aus Deutschland
ausgelagert und die Politik sagte wir
werden eine
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft das war hier
die Ansage aber das gehört mittlerweile
auch der Vergangenheit an auch
Dienstleistungen werden mehr und mehr
ausgelagert und da frage ich Sie warum
sollte sich überhaupt noch ein
Unternehmen in Deutschland ansiedeln
diese Frage können sie überhaupt nicht
mehr beantworten denn die Ursachen sind
nicht klar und die benennen sie kaum
noch hohe Sozialabgaben Steuerlast die
zu hoch ist Bürokratie und natürlich
nicht die zuletzt hohen Energiepreise
tragen genau dazu bei dass dieser
Wirtschaftssektor auch bald nicht mehr
existiert und das Deutschland auch keine
Wirtschaftsnation in dem Umfang mehr
sein wird
Beispiele sehen wir hier gerade auch in
Berlin tagtäglich Handwerksbetriebe wie
Bäckereien schließen und die Gastronomie
kann keine Angebote mehr machen weil die
Arbeitskräfte fehlen und das in einer
Bundeshauptstadt den sie mal in ihren
Wahlkreis insofern sie überhaupt einen
haben und schauen sich die Lage mal vor
Ort an können sie ihren Wählern
eigentlich diesen Niedergang überhaupt
noch vermitteln und wenn ich die
Abwanderung mal betrachte die ja auch in
keinen Kontext mehr gesetzt wird seit
2014 verlassen jährlich fast 250.000
Deutsche dieses Land das sind bis zum
Jahr 2020 zwei Millionen Deutsche
Leistungsträger die dieses Land
verlassen und sie reden immer wieder von
Zuwanderung die Gründe dafür die sollten
Sie mal ermitteln denn das ist ein
Skandal
und sie dürfen mir glauben dass die
Bürger sehen und erleben Tag für Tag die
Folgen ihrer destruktiven Politik denn
diese führt unser Land auch in die
energiepolitische Sackgasse mit ihrer
Entscheidung die grundlassfähigen
Energieträger wie Kohle Gas aber auch
Kernkraft aus Deutschland zu verbannen
enthalten sie Bürgern und Unternehmen
die kontinuierliche Energieversorgung
vor und nein die aktuelle der
dunkelflauten können sie eben nicht
beeinflussen wohl aber ein vernünftigen
Energiemix wie wir es von der AFD immer
wieder gefordert haben sie als
Bundesregierung werden mehr und mehr zum
Treiber der Inflation sie sind die
Hauptursache der Inflation in
Deutschland
und deshalb machen sie die
energiepolitische Kehrtwende machen sie
endlich Politik für Deutschland und für
die Bürger sie haben die Aufgabe auch in
schwierigen Zeiten realpolitische
Lösungsansätze zu erarbeiten stattdessen
hören sie auf ihre Ideologie immer
wieder mit neuen Bedrohungsszenarien
durchsetzen zu wollen und wir die
Opposition werden sie immer wieder in
die Pflicht nehmen politiksymbole des
deutschen Volkes zu machen wir die
Opposition dieses Hohen Hauses haben die
Aufgabe ihre
Regierungspolitik kritisch zu begleiten
das ist der Kern unserer demokratischen
parlamentarischen Ordnung und nicht
Ihnen auf der Regierungsbank mit warmen
Worten zu schmeicheln das machen sie
jeden Tag schon selbst genug vielen Dank
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]